[Musique]
nous voici donc à télécom paris
prestigieuse école d'ingénieurs une
école qui fait sa première vraie rentrée
pas les iem il ya 3000 élèves alors à
cause de la qu'ovide effectivement ils
sont beaucoup moins nombreux mais le
directeur de cet établissement est avec
nous bonjour nicolas glady bonjour merci
d'être avec nous donc une rentrée un peu
compliqué à cause de lakovic vous étiez
prêts alors on a commencé à travailler
sur cette question là en fait dès mai
avant la rentrée puisqu'on a établi un
groupe de travail spécifique sur la
question de la rentrée sous pandémie est
donc hors on a dans un premier temps
fait avec ce groupe de travail établi
toutes les modalités pédagogiques qu'on
pouvait envisager succo vide dans un
premier temps et puis on a fait remonter
sur base de ce travail préliminaire les
attentes à la fois des étudiants et des
enseignants-chercheurs et donc une fois
qu'on avait toutes ces informations n'a
pu établir un planning de rentrée qu'on
avait donc établi dans
les quelques semaines qui ont précédé
septembre qu'on a fait bien sûr aussi
valider auprès des différentes instances
le chsct etc
pour avoir la rentrée qu'on a
aujourd'hui la chance qu'on a eu aussi
c'est qu'on a un tout nouveau bâtiment
on en parlera certainement et donc avec
aussi des espaces qui se prête à de
l'espace justement entre les étudiants
puisque c'est que c'est important et les
modalités pédagogiques en digital avec
des caméras des micros qui fonctionne
bien des écrans qui font retour des gens
qui pouvaient être à distance qui nous a
permis en fait d'avoir très rapidement
et aussi avec un peu de travail il faut
le dire la possibilité d'avoir des
centres d enseignement hybride
alors pour ceux qui ont la chance d'être
ici dans ce bâtiment c'est vous là vous
l'avez dit c'est un bâtiment tout neuf
qui a été primé les architectes ont été
primés c'est un peu un lieu presque
monacale c'est ça c'est comment rentrer
à athée comme paris ont ont fait une
profession de foi on alors moi j'aime
beaucoup effectivement nous inscrire
dans la tradition académique à la
tradition académique vient effectivement
du monde ecclésiastique y en a on a une
histoire commune sur tout un tas de
dimensions alors effectivement je ne
dirais pas qu'elle transfère chercheurs
c'est un sacerdoce
mais quand même c'est certainement il
faut avoir une fois dans la vérité et sa
recherche qui est très très forte que
moi j'aime beaucoup effectivement se
rappelle à l'histoire de nos
établissements et des établissement
centenaire est la plupart des écoles de
l'institut polytechnique de paris ont
d'ailleurs parmi les écoles membre d'un
institut polytechnique de paris la plus
vieille école d'ingénieur avec
l'einstein le coeur effectivement
s'inscrit dans une tradition longue
effectivement le cabinet d'architectes
grafton qui a conçu ce bâtiment s'est
imprégné s'est inspiré de l'histoire
alors monacale 2
de ce genre d'établissement merci
beaucoup a dit d'avoir accueilli dans ce
magnifique bâtiment tout neuf et pour
cette première vraie rentrée falaisienne
merci merci à vous
[Musique]